Well,
I mean,
I guess the hard lines,
secularism is not a good idea.
Uh,
which is not to say that secularism is
not a good idea.
I mean,
I,
I've,
I certainly think that the attempt in
the United States to buy groups here to
rewrite American history as a sort of
Christian story and to portray the
founding fathers as,
as,
um,
Christian fathers is something that
really needs to be challenged.
And,
and in the name of,
of secular in the name of history,
but accurate history as well as
everything else.
But I think the kind of hard,
no secularism of France that kind of,
um,
unbending insistence on,
that secular means one thing and that
violations of it are,
will not be tolerated in any way is a
bad idea.
Um,
and that if you're accommodating,
um,
different groups,
different populations,
um,
what you need to do is figure out ways
of accommodating them.
The way the French did when they passed
the 1905 loss separating church and
state the way they did with the Catholic
church.
There was a day off for religious
instruction for kids.
All the holidays in France still,
or some are state holidays,
but most of them are Catholic,
not even just Christian Catholic
holidays.
Um,
parts of France are Alsace.
And Lorraine Alsace Moselle those
departments which were,
um,
under German control when the 1905 law
was passed and then came back to France
after the war.
Those con,
those areas were never forced to adopt
the secular practices that the rest of
the country,
uh,
adopted.
So still in those areas,
you can have religious teaching in
schools,
children have to take a course in
religious instruction and so on and so
forth.
So if they're not even consistent,
it's not even a nationally consistent
policy in relation to Catholicism,
which was the dominant religion at the
time the law was passed.
So to act as if it's either secularism
or nothing,
or that the secular and the religious
are in eternal opposition to each other
is to misrepresent French history and to
create a situation in which they will
only be a greater sense of,
um,
felt discrimination and,
anger on the part of the population's
whom these these laws affect.
Uh,
so,
uh,
it seems to me that that kind of hard
lines,
secularism,
which is as fundamentalist in its way as
the most extreme Islam Islamist
fundamentalism is defeats its own
purpose and really doesn't,
um,
ended up producing a situation in which
there can be a certain kind of
pluralism,
cultural pluralism and political
assimilation and political citizenship.